bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
video sono affari generali siano
tantissimi fans con il buon pietro
allora ragazzi nuova partita è da una
vita che non giochiamo a sic si seccano
abbiamo deciso di giocarla oggi perché
parlando tra me e lui non è mai finito
così ho vinto un paio di volte sarà
porca [ __ ] detto io vado io ero un po
il mio figlio allora non permetta
professore aspetta il tempo lo prende il
tasto niente ma non sei capace
dovrete le cose adesso aprendo alla fine
ha detto e la figlia per i punti della
figlia poverina ma poi abbiamo perso ma
come abbiamo già detto ma dai ma cibo
per indire cosi le maggio mia moglie la
mamma grazie dritta ma perché torni così
sottili zitto zitto nell'acqua l'acqua
l'acqua giunta la con la zuppa quindi
napoli già agricola regione valigia ci
hanno riso dietro dice la valigia metodo
ma potrei affollato di giornali ma che
cazzo scegliere il canestro aiuto
affetti adam trans colin firth a
prendere da ma torna indietro
c'era ma non ci sa le cose qui la
macchina la maschera pensiero basket
spegne diretti per le altre robe da era
roba di perfetto torna dentro essere
quasi nova moriamo sai qua 6 4 6 4
miu miu che partirà il cavolo la città
sa mai non sei capanno che ha dei ser
analizza i cieli computer sono robe
dentro e accrescere gli altri sono ora
guarda io prendo questa con seriamente
per me la famiglia luce sopravviva
accendi la luce a cosa pensa o gesù
spiegare questa valigia della minchia
che cosa dovrebbe fare spiega da cose
allora va bene
giorno 1 va bene c'è un problema e vabbè
che vuoi
non c'è la maschera si e no ci serve la
madre serve niente come non ci serve si
fece che faccio io gli ho detto tu si no
si va al giorno due chissà se magari il
mondo rosa io primi tre quattro giorni
fa ci mancava ascoltami visto che mary
jane da inutile la cacciò fuori dal
bunker
perché inutile perché non fa niente ma
non ci basta mary jennings si sente alla
grande e bellissima cosa di buono dopo c
ad aprile non apprendono l'ho chiamata
con una porta lan i militari maggior
recco che si rifiuta riderà anni la
madonna un po troppo speed dopo un po
bussare cessalto responsabili sono
andato fiero scopriremo mai era solihull
paolo cento che mi piace secondo te ecco
questa domanda adesso che sta uscendo
chi lo devo dare la roba io però agli
altri sì ma stiamo di nola napoli senza
niente sono scemo magari muore magari
magari magari mora garioni non torni
stavano qualche ottimo scelta conclude
bene è facile sentirsi giù di morale
quando si è dotata niente solenne scudo
secondo bene che verrà stiamo qua 50
giorno e che è vuoi veramente di tutte
le cazzate che sparo l'emersione di
queste cose invece un anche di prisco
bravissimo neanch'io infatti soffitta a
farlo youtuber pure tu hai visto in tv
prima di però si è poi cedere il posto
dedica mente ma da quando da sempre ma
non lo sapremo mai se come mai non vinco
maghi mia volta far rimangiare dopo
sette giorni insiste anche no quando ho
segnato
bravi i ragni e grazie infatti semplice
se non ci laviamo ci viene da ravaglia
casse versi l'impiego accusa sul serio
cia magari sopportarvi usa lo spray ma
magari se ti ci dà ci laviamo un po ma
l'hai mai fatto lei sta dicendo la prima
volta non è mai fatto che si sentono
questo caso
se tu fossi un apporto cibo secondo che
non ha portato gli asili si guarda più
in acqua amica è utile papa stava bene
devi sapere del pieno di ottimismo e
ancora del tipo che il passo avanti ma
poverino in pieno di massa ma
dall'ottimismo e profumo delle
radiazioni a chernobyl va bene se
qualcuno ci può salvare la questa
situazione e radio maria lai che anche
qui sotto assolutamente sì fedeli e
pacate le mattine alle sei del mattino i
governi e non è caduto e sta muovendo
salvarci se abbiamo vinto con b ma mi
spieghi perché devi saltare con dice kg
e mangiare chi deve esser leggere e
incredibile veri geni reagisce benissimo
la situazione oggi sembra stare bene ma
organizzano da mika stagione andrà a
clash royale di bella la sua barba mi
piacesse molto io frammenti lui si
sarebbe anche giulia si parla così non è
anche scene anche quella sud ad ora si
era preoccupata tende sta bene sembra
che abbia sempre radiato sci
investimento e pericolo ma aspettiamo
altro ci pensa la società tratterebbe di
siete l'unico libro che abbiamo letto
tutti l'elenco telefonico
io non ho letto neanche quello che erano
profughi sembra vissuti ma lo stavano
peggio e ci hanno pregato di dargli
qualcosa diamoli must have
credimi cibo che lei era cibo dobbiamo
da basta se ne sono andati non sarebbero
rai.tv bevesse non superiore a fare
acqua acqua quando iberia fogli bianchi
e verde
oggi abbiamo conosciuto tipo
incredibilmente saranno aveva un aspetto
umano ma anche tre paia di mani in più a
cera contatto di un gruppo di un
[ __ ] che racconta di avere un gruppo
di persone con lui che aveva difficoltà
a procurarsi provviste già fatto
un'offerta se condividiamo colore alcune
nostre scorte ci proteggeranno nella
prossima spedizione
assolutamente sì sì sembrano tutte le
nostre provvisti in giro al nuovo amico
e mi chiamo di scoraggiare
secondo me moio giorno 19 la lettera
fuori ste cose mi fermo un anno di tipo
ma che si ammazzino ultimato sono morto
perché non riuscire a mettere carte per
i militari
i militari sti minchia di marin si
trovano solo se metti le carte fuori non
una scritta siamo qui non la cai quattro
tipi che vogliono loro fuori porca vacca
io non gliele 9 galera da niente ma ce
l'abbiamo
due di queste in cambio della maschera
che c'abbiamo la maschera no però mi 4
acqua e massicci del no no no 4 a quasi
48 miglia la fisici danno io non vorrei
giriamo la fisi ma se tu non è mai vinto
in questo gioco
vuol dire che vinco adesso più 4 ea e
meno di una mary jane e suadente visione
di acqua visto visto che servono subito
gli do tutto e lido anche da zucchero
gli adorati dai team i nodi vitrioli
vedo benissimo e possiamo dai sensi dai
lanusei dai marinai ragazzo o una
valigia perché perché portafortuna la
valigia cambierà hicks
vabbè che mi ha dato la fuori con la
valigetta partono più di lavoro dei
mutanti oggi ha così interrotto liso che
lascia spazio nato comunicato
dell'esercito si dovrà guardare ma tra
villeggiare amica sarà da parlare
abbiamo ricevuto delle coordinate
specifiche per te ne vai vai mai tanti
sì sì mai ma avevo già fatto stavano
arriva nessuno arriva fa niente è
tornato è tornato cibo cibo figlio che
la tutto miglietti compro call of duty
dalla madonna ed è andato all'esselunga
abarth a origgio ci piaceva è abilissima
devo la valigia libri e mangiare bere
però è malika lido tutti gli occhi le
[ __ ] da molta fame le stanco la sete
mandare avanti le bere tutti quanti
sticazzi da un giorno e oggi è pasqua è
pasqua e passa giorno 30 il record non
verrebbero 60 70 e non hai vinto
no forse è come se di ragni fossero
commenti di avere lì non si sa se gli in
assist in gli stessi a era italiano
l'asso che siccome nostra riesca a lei
usa ha usati proprio scout schiaccia i
ragni esatto guarda che utilissimo quel
cono siro è tornata mary jane cosa sia
soltanto bella uno di sviluppa duri
acqua e la realtà mascara manda lei
manda lei a mani vuote così così a
moneyvall a mani vuote
stamani moneyvall o ama di morte la
faremo mai al giorno 36 arriva la faremo
mai
riponiamo la maschera antigas libero di
pesca va veramente ora ci posso credere
che volge guarda guarda guarda non c'è
più questa rotta ci abbiamo messo a
tavola cosa non ha funzionato per la
valletta maschera andate in pezzi ma no
è storia di giovanni mucciaccia
aranzulla 5 quando stamane aveva aperto
la porta del punto per far entrare aria
fresca e radioattivi dei geni signor
abbiamo scoperto una valigetta solutions
nera come allora quella valigetta
contiene di soldi una bottiglia d'acqua
che punta può essere buona o cattiva 6
cattiva mo si ammala
quindi direi che la tranciatura esatto
non rischiamo niente
weiss a queste cose quando ha giocato ha
sta roba è un po di fango torna più
andata si è fermato
il mercato si facesse annusare vinciamo
vinciamo vinciamo ivy canalino ma i
militari non si vince sulla ritornata
dopo ok con con una sega
niente dei progetti senza munizioni
tremonti e dvd per la traccia veraclasse
avuti dai team mi può farcela vedo l'ora
di partire dai vari temi oggi siamo un
po spaventati quando aveva per caduta
ripreso nel mondo si chiama sì sì sì con
23 mou dovrebbe essere da cassaforti
dietro il bye bye abbiamo la pelle ma io
non so se gesù moriamo tutti escluso
alla tirati dentro te l'immagini matrone
credibile a roma acqua che uno album
ragazzo alla vista qualche non siamo
messi male ma di un motivo in bosnia la
casa senza niente proiettili
ma cosa gli lancio delle freccette le
freccette la scena la nasa ha lasciati a
medicina avesse compiuto gli anni due
settimane fa male gravi le carte del
cavallino rigido ma se le avessero un
mangano lì rimangono non melarancia
tutto mangia un pollo e la bacia
vado ruolo ti ammazzo sono rimaste lì ma
che ca ga nel gene ad ora le carte
perché siamo andati vicino già andati è
è tornato theory e 47 acqua guarigione
di alla grande sappiamo che un
insegnante locale ha salvato di bambini
di questo se ne conosciamo le promesse
casettine rifugio scolasti abbiamo ai
bambini
l'ultima volta che ha rubato in un bar
di vecchietti erano armati ce l'avete
ora fatto un culo cooder ammette ero
duro quanto cibo
i bambini morti ma non è benissimo cosa
per oggi non ha dato problemi o forse
brano avuto il coraggio di dar noia
senzani basta dargli cose perché la
valigetta e dei contratti ma parla cisco
grafici giorno 50 numero tondo questo è
stata arriveremo ai 220 armi e se noi
cambiate un altro unica tra l'isola di
tali zone hanno ordinato a tutti
rappresentati i sopravvissuti di uscire
per incontrare la mano la situazione
quando le squadre dai dai dai dai dai
così non dico ma sex miranda si stanno
dando da salvare i battezzati clan chi
va al menu sale perché si ha preso un po
di appunti elettrici avrebbe fatto
sapere lo farebbero sapere bomber viene
scappato veramente perché possiamo dare
qualcun altro fuori quindi utile scappò
da cosa vuol dire è di certo ne volle
che sono seguite solo scacciamosche esce
così pensava calamari già ora si è
mangiata valigia per l'eta vergognano
era di marca licia di winton [ __ ]
storia il power già mia ora di ascoltare
un po di radio martin carico gesù ti
prego aiutaci darci un segno dei
militari ti prego buongiorno 58 che ha
fatto di peggio
che cos'altro tranquilli per dolore
tranquilli questo qualcuno che ti chiave
la porta come se non ci fosse un domani
realtà potrebbe essere la mente così sì
perché rosa i militari e sono i militari
dobbiamo avere parlo non ci crederà
segreti
io vado mica ci credono mai vinto starò
ma ben 200 euro
porca vacca gioco di me bodies in stallo
di vista
basta basta non serve a niente dalla
distanza ma cosa si faceva culo gioco di
me ragazzo spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto
grazie a ecco proprio partecipato fatto
segnato al merito suo e del libro dei
boy scout libro di questo però mi sia
piaciuto ragazzi cosa di scrivere
l'argomento o vi piace mi chiama ci
posso credere te lo giuro
sono veramente il nome di certo mi hai
fatto senza vestiti leggeri e noi ci
vediamo un po si sa molto bene grazie
[Musica]